hello and welcome to the new world
review source for everything anime and
manga quite specifically jiu-jitsu
kaisen and even more specifically
specifically we are here to rank every
domain featured thus far in the series
why you ask
well i ask you in return why not but
it's a surprisingly difficult thing to
do actually because the entire principle
behind domains is that they act as these
instant win conditions in the vast
majority of curse-related combat so it's
like going into a deck of cards and
trying to rank all of the aces without
any knowledge of suit order the domains
are great jujutsu kaisen
also great and you the viewer viewing
this viewable media
are even better than great so we're
going to do it regardless and it's all
going to commence with a quick round of
oh no
i've been caught in a domain a very
simple minigame the rules of which are
as follows you have been unfortunate
enough to have been iso kite into the
jujutsu kaisen world and upon arriving
you encounter these three characters
one of them is going to trap you in
their domain and it is going to be your
job to guess which it will be
should you guessing correctly then your
punishment will be to subscribe to the
new world review thus resulting in
consistent injections of jiu-jitsu
sorcery administered straight into your
youtube feed and if you do guess
correctly then you will be spared from
your brutal
domain-y fate but which domain will it
be a b
or c make your choice now and we shall
reveal the answer in
three two one and bam it is sukuna's
malevolent shrine
that's unfortunate unfortunate for you
so if you guessed incorrectly then you
know thing to do and please do say hi in
the comments below if you are a new
member of the channel
welcome in the meantime at the time of
this recording we have eight
domains to rank sort of it's more like
seven and a half to be honest with you
because despite how fast and furiously
these bad boys were thrown at us in the
early days of the series domains are
actually pretty incredibly rare oh and
you know what this might also be a great
time to mention that this video will
include manga spoilers because we've got
some fun stuff to talk about there for
anime only watches apologies for that
but it's pretty difficult to do a video
like this without going into uh
how shall we say certain details but
with that said our easy answer to the
question of which domain ranks in dead
last is of course
the simple domain it's more on this list
due to a technicality because it's
actually designed as a domain
countermeasure but it does still result
in a very similar effect by creating a
unique area of control and even
sometimes granting its users special
abilities within said area and one good
example of this would be miwa whose
simple domain allowed her to
automatically strike anyone who entered
it even then though sadly it's not a
guaranteed hit because particularly fast
opponents can
will and have avoided it which sure is
far from the instant win condition that
most real domains present but it's
actually quite effective when utilized
well however another issue with simple
domains is that they can also come
equipped with some rather detrimental
activation requirements
to go back to the case of meanwhile once
again she is not allowed to move her
feet after activation or the simple
domain will cease to exist and in the
end simple domains well they're more of
a handy utility that seemingly anyone
can learn however that's also no fun
because the true domain is very much an
expression of a curse uses inner
workings and for an example of that we
now move to number seven
the chimera shadow gun a domain wielded
by one
megami fushiguru which is mercifully
easy to rank as it was identified as an
incomplete domain expansion
and has yet to be fully refined by the
increasingly overpowered existence that
is fushiguru and i suppose the most
interesting thing about the domain as it
stands would be that its ability
provides far more mental and strategic
advantage than it does this overwhelming
physical power-based victory the domain
may get to that stage in the future but
right now it's selling point is that it
allows fushiguru to make full use of his
imagination via the wonderful and
copious substance of
shadow goop in theory it may allow
fushiguru to do just about anything and
when i say anything i mean manipulating
the shadow garden to assume seemingly
any form including creating duplicates
of fushiguru himself these constructs
themselves don't pose too much of a
threat to a skilled opponent but it's
more about how they're used very
tactically in conjunction with
fushigura's standard sorcery although i
have to say my favorite thing about
kamera shadowgarden is that it unleashes
a side of fushiguro that we almost never
get to see a man
unbound by all of the constraints of the
world around him someone who is free to
be truly selfish and it really does seem
to be a very cathartic experience for
him which is nice it's very nice and all
but it's still
seventh place moving on to the coveted
sixth position we have an unnamed domain
of the smallpox deity which i will say
right here and now is the domain that
probably interests me the most because
of its series of conditions and also
it's
it's just it's general existence it's
fun it's cool and it's weird
the smallpox deity itself being a
special grade cursed spirit under the
control of
not ghetto which means that it
implemented its domain with an almost ai
style of operation
you know like if you're in the boss
battle of a game and you identify a
clear pattern that the boss never
deviates from no matter what that
is the smallpox deity but it is still
quite terrifying because the idea is
that this domain traps its target within
a coffin which is then smooshed by a big
old death rock
and then after a three second countdown
the target is infected with a fatal
disease
a disease that will render them rather
dead but luckily they're already in a
coffin underground so the funeral
arrangements have already been taken
care of but yes this domain has
quite a few steps to go through but i
really do like all of those fun
technicalities the true reason why it
ranks so lowly however is because of the
ai function i mentioned earlier the
smallpox deity has a design flaw whereby
it automatically targets the strongest
source of cursed energy which does make
it very susceptible to tactical
manipulation and injured sky senate
tends to be a big problem if a combatant
cannot think efficiently much less when
they cannot think
at all so with that in mind this is
where we land but landing slightly
better than that
is number five horizon of the
captivating skandha and this i will say
is by far the most pleasant of all of
the domains we'll be exploring
potentially
better because we're not being used to
brutally dismember targets with its
fish-based shikigami and actually serves
as quite a delightful holiday spot
the domain itself is wielded by dagon
who is unfortunately the least explored
of all of the cursed nature dudes but
even then this domain does tell us quite
a bit about him being a creature who
desires the peace and beauty of nature
but also not being afraid to weaponize
that nature to destroy those who would
seek to destroy it and as a quick side
note we never saw hanami's domain
expansion but i imagine that it would
have been very similar to this
like a delightful stunning flower field
that can morph into an army of
apocalyptic plant
things but back to dagon this domain is
slightly disappointing in that it's very
straightforward in its approach people
get trapped on the beach or in the water
and then they're assaulted by a myriad
of shikigami and i feel like that's a
bit underwhelming because it almost
seems like a version of the chimera
shadow garden that lacks the nuance and
versatility of fushiguru's use
however in place of that nuance is a
complete domain and raw power i guess
that's the thing dagon's death swarm is
more than enough to eventually overwhelm
almost any opponent dagon just got quite
unlucky with the particular group he
encountered in the same way that jogo
tends to get quite unlucky with gojo
and speaking of we have number four
coffin of the iron mountain
and this would be the second domain that
we are knowingly exposed to in the
series that's right jogo exposed himself
to us
nasty little spirit thing but unlike his
peace-loving nature counterparts
coffin of the iron mountain probably
represents the peak fury of the natural
world
essentially locking its targets within
an active volcano which means that
they're going to be attacked with all
sorts of things
things like fire magma fissures and this
domain also comes with an added bonus of
raw heat the environmental conditions
alone would kill most victims of this
domain without
ever needing to launch any attacks
whatsoever jogo's domain is simply that
brutal
it really is one of the most terrifying
yet underrated abilities within the
series because jogo's juxtaposition has
been highly unfavorable his two main
conflicts injured sky sin just so
happened to be against gojo and sukuna
which provides a very poor and sad
impression of jogo's power he is
insanely strong and within this domain
unless you are one of the aforementioned
two characters
it is almost certainly going to
obliterate you with that said i still
don't think it's quite as good as
number three self-embodiment of
perfection so next up we have majito's
creepy creepy handsy touchy feely domain
and the main reason why i would have
placed this above kaufman of the iron
mountain is because with majito's domain
there is no need to perform an attack at
all
anybody caught within self-embodiment of
perfection will have their soul subject
to mahito's idol transfiguration without
the need for him to physically touch
them
souls are just automatically and very
non-consensually touched by this domain
which is amazing unless it's used in one
specific situation where the soul of
someone much more powerful than you
is you know felt up and in the case of
sukuna he really did not appreciate this
soul harassment
resulting in mojito's grand punishment i
really don't see that as too much of a
drawback to the domain in general though
i mean provided sukuna is not within the
domain this
that's as good as done and what i'll
also say is that this to me is probably
the most horrifying domain expansion
from a perspective of pure terror i hate
this i hate this so much the sprawling
hands in the darkness is pure nightmare
fuel and the idea that you are now
under the complete control of the
grotesque desires of mahito is far more
unpleasant than the idea of being caught
in a really violent domain like jojo's
or honestly
anyone else's domain even the ones we
still have yet to explore which leads us
quite nicely into
number two which is malevolent shrine
the domain of mr sukuna himself this is
probably the most unique technique that
we have on today's ranking and that
comes down to pure experience
sukuna aka the king of the curses has an
understanding of wielding cursed energy
far more in depth than most so what we
have is a domain that does not utilize
the standard advantage of a domain which
would be the creation of a barrier to
trap its target instead if one is caught
within malevolent shrine they are
actually 100 capable of moving outside
of it
should they find the escape route the
problem being that in exchange for this
escape condition
sukuna is capable of increasing the
radius of the guaranteed domain hit
ability
like significantly increase to an area
that covers a maximum radius of 200
meters if desired from there sukuno can
use dismantle and cleave as necessary to
attack anyone or anything within this
area until glorious glorious death and
or destruction has been achieved ideally
both and like all true domains this does
say quite a bit about sukuna himself he
is so confident in his own abilities
that he exists to make sport of cursed
combat to be entertained as the
king he is so he allows his targets to
have the hope of escape whilst choosing
to hunt them in these very very gory
ways
dismantle and cleave are not the most
efficient of killing techniques but to
sukuna they are the most
fun so there is that and of course the
scariest thing is that we haven't even
seen tsukuna utilize his domain at full
power so things could get
even more insane in the future perhaps
even elevating malevolent shrine to the
coveted status of
first place however for now our
undisputed winner is pretty obviously
going to be
unlimited void or limitless void or even
immeasurable void you can call it
whatever you want because after becoming
trapped in this domain you will have
immediate
access to a full thesaurus of every
language and in fact every piece of
information about everything
ever you'll be so overwhelmed with
knowledge that you will become paralyzed
by choice not knowing what to fixate on
and i think i said this in one of my
reviews of the series but it's kind
of like when you're out with a group of
friends and you're trying to decide
where to eat
it is absolutely frustratingly
impossible because you're all frozen by
the amount of choice and until someone
takes charge you're all just going to
stand there and slowly starve to death
which is very much how gojo's domain
functions the target afflicted by all of
this knowledge will just stand there and
slowly die
unable to function in any way shape or
form that or gojo will take the
opportunity to kill them swiftly if they
are lucky
that's a big if so it really is
difficult to go past unlimited void as
an utterly dominant
domain thing particularly because gojo
can use it multiple times within a
single day
something that no other true domain user
has been capable of at this point so as
per usual anything involving satoru gojo
will end up with satoru gojo on top as
he will be awarded with the bestest of
all of the domains
in jujutsu kaisen but now that you've
seen the best go and see
something else something else on this
channel to be precise like this video
it's going to be good fun i promise so i
look forward to
seeing you there